this episode is brought to you by our
friends at Nord VPN check out Nord VPN
comm slash what F and use the coupon
code what if that's one word to get 70%
off a three year plan plus one month for
free
imagine what it would be like if you
could wake up in your New York City
apartment at 7 a.m. and make it to your
job in London England by 9:30 in the
morning that would be a possibility if
we dug tunnels between the two contents
just try not to get sick believe it or
not something like this is possible but
how do we make a tunnel like this and
how much would it cost this is what if
and here's what would happen if we dug
tunnels between continents that's right
a tunnel like this
is possible I mean a tunnel that's
similar to this already exists it's
called the channel tunnel or tunnel and
in just about 35 minutes you can drive
from England to France without it you'd
have to take either a ferry or a plane
compared to what we'd be building the
tunnel is tiny at just over 50
kilometres our tunnel would be over
5,500 kilometers if we wanted to go from
New York to London so how would we make
our tunnel let's use the Channel Tunnel
as an example of what our tube might
look like to give us some context the
Channel Tunnel took six years to build
and it also took decades of planning
before that as for the price if we were
to build another channel today it would
cost a whopping 13 billion dollars ok
now multiply these numbers by 100 as
that is how much bigger our tunnel would
be and you get the idea this thing would
take an incredibly long time and would
cost a ridiculous amount of money but
let's assume we've got all this covered
and we have unlimited time and money
just because we have enough resources
doesn't mean we should be stupid and how
we use them if we tried to avoid all the
water and went underneath the sea floor
we'd have to bore through the ground
from England all the way to America this
would take an incredibly long time
and there's always the possibility that
the tunnel we built more than 5,000
meters underwater would cave in from the
oceans pressure instead the best way to
make the tunnel might be like this you
would make one massively long 5500
kilometer tube and put it over the ocean
then using anchors you would drag the
tube down about 45 meters you would then
secure the tube using wires tied to the
oceans floor okay now that we have our
tunnel what do we fill it with will we
drive through it that's so 21st century
instead we'll be taking a train I know I
know that might sound even more
old-school than using a car but this
won't be just a regular train to travel
through our tube so quickly we'd need to
use vac trains this system would
essentially act as a vacuum that would
take all the air out of the tube this
would allow the train to travel at
incredibly high speeds due to there
being little or no air resistance not
only that but our train would also be
levitating using high-powered magnets or
with air kind of like an air hockey
table where I'm a Canadian sad after
propelling the train forward with a
high-powered engine that could cruise
for hundreds if not thousands of
kilometres since there's no friction to
stop it with this little resistance the
vac train can go up to 8,000 kilometers
per hour but we won't be going that fast
as that could be incredibly dangerous
not just for the train but for your
physical well-being instead you'd be
going about 2,000 kilometers which is
almost double the speed of sound but
don't be too alarmed by this your body
should be able to handle it just fine
after all the Concorde passenger jet
flew this fast for years before it was
decommissioned
so it is possible that we'll see a pipe
that connects across the Atlantic Ocean
one day as long as we have enough money
time and resources now imagine that the
supersonic train actually exists and we
could casually travel from Europe to
America in just under an hour
think about how industry our economy and
travel would change but what if we never
even had to travel from Europe to
America as the land masses were already
connected well that sounds like a story
for another what in hey once again we
just like to thank this videos sponsor
Nord VPN Nord VPN gives you a virtual
private network that keeps your browsing
history safe from any bad guys trying to
get your data passwords or information
we really like north VPN here at what-if
because it gives us unlimited access to
the Internet
ever browse YouTube and suddenly you
can't watch a video because it's not
available in your country
well Nord VPN solves this by masking
your IP address giving the illusion that
you're in any country you want to be in
virtually speaking you can get your own
VPN at Nord VPN comm / what if make sure
to use the coupon code what if one word
to get 70% off a three-year plan plus
one month free
you